In all of the piecewise functions we've looked at so far, the endpoints of each
of the segments have matched up with one another exactly. Which makes the
graphs continuous. There are no breaks. Now when this is the case, we can
choose to include these boundary values. These values of x where we switch from
one part of the function to the other. To be in either of the two parts of the
function that come together at that point. We don't want any over lapse
however. So in the case of this last function we were looking at. We initially
included that x equals 0 point. In the probable part of the function. Which is
why we had 0 is less than or equal to x is less than 3. As the domain, for this
middle piece of the function. We could however instead, include 0 in this first
linear part, the negative one half of x minus 4 part of the function. If we
decide to pursue that, we'd have to switch off our inequalities over here. So
instead of having 0 is less than or equal to x right here you have 0 is less
than X. I would switch the equal to part to be here over. So domain for this
first line is negative five is less than or equal to x, less than or equal to
0. We could do the same thing with x equals 3. And now we can see it's
contained in the f of x equals x minus four portions. This line right here. We
could instead, include it in the parabola if we just made x is less than or
equal to 3. Instead of x is less than 3, and if we just switch this to less
than sign. Sometimes however, piecewise functions aren't continuous. They often
have breaks in them. But sometimes Piecewise Functions aren't continuous. They
often have breaks in them, as you can see in the two functions I've drawn here.
Now, if you want to show that a certain point is not defined on a function, or
in other words, if you want to exclude its X coordinate from the domain. We
just draw a little open circle at that point like I've done in several places
here. Now, for each of these two piecewise functions here, I'd like you to
decide which of these end points should stay open. And which ones should be
filled on, based of course on how I've defined the domains for either of the
functions. If you think an endpoint should be filled in, just click the circle
that's at that endpoint. And if you want it to stay open, then just leave it
open. Don't mark it. To double-check your work, you can make sure that there's
no x value on either of these graphs that belongs to two different parts of the
functions.